today on first we feast and complex boy
DJ Paul kale will go teach you how to
pimp out your Super Bowl spread going
down No
today we're gonna do sighs man you got
to have vegetables I love vegetables and
you might have a vegetarian at your
party we're gonna do something Sookie
knee and squash it's gonna look good
it's gonna taste good
we're gonna do some tomatoes with basil
and garlic we're gonna put it all in the
looming foil and cook it on the grill so
it's gonna be a super easy simple wait
you're gonna love it all right you got
to have vegetables vegetables on the
grill that's better than anything
everybody know about zucchini squash on
the grill that's pretty basic just a
little with a little olive oil or EVO Oh
then we're gonna hit it with some DJ
Paul owner things seasoning we got some
special things we're gonna do to the
zucchini and squash at the end right now
I want to get to the good part I call
this the Italian stallion aka the
Italian flag and that's pretty cool
that's rise I got some roasted tomato
garlic basil doesn't feta cheese but I
couldn't really make that in the round
so we're gonna drizzle a little little
olive oil
hit it with the DJ Paul aren't
everything seasoning I'm go too crazy
with it you're gonna follow this good
sort of steam and there you have it that
simple we're gonna throw this right on
the grill just like this
so now we just grid a zucchini and
squash go to Parmesan cheese on there
lies still high so you get all melted
and beautiful looking great beautiful
grill marks on it right now for they go
out there and check out my Italian flag
I'll be right back my Italian flag right
here ready to go woo garlic hits his
soldier open them up so there you have
it grilled vegetables DJ Paul style love
y'all buon appetito
Jackson for more my Super Bowl recipes
click on the videos to the right for
everything else keep it locked to
complex